Welcome to the wonderful Iguazu Falls.
The splendor of the falls with its misty rainbows is almost overwhelming.
There is simply nothing else like it in the world.
Millions of years ago, natural forces split up the Earth's crust,...
...creating what the indigenous Guarani people called "The Great Waters".
Iguazu Falls is 1.7 miles wide and is not one but an astonishing 275 waterfalls.
Eighty percent of the falls lies in Argentina and 20% in Brazil.
Follow the boardwalk trail through the jungle...
...and stand on viewing platforms opposite,...
...or, if you're feeling brave, on the top of the falls.
Feel humbled by the power of the tumbling water mass below you.
In the wet season, a maximum of nearly 13,000 cubic meters of water,...
...that's 450,000 cubic feet, thunders over the combined falls each second.